Christian Bale famously starred as
Patrick Bateman an American Psycho oh my
God he is so good in that it hurts but
he revealed that it's really only
because Leo turned it down and suspected
that Leo is the first pick for every
leading role in Hollywood and if other
actors get the part only if Leo passes
and he said all of this with love and
admiration for Leo okay so this is funny
I know that Leonardo was definitely
supposed to be in Boogie Nights and then
really he turned it down only to have
Mark Wahlberg give I think one of the
most revelatory performances in cinema
history he was amazing
Mark Wahlberg was Dirk Diggler and that
catapulted his career he was Marky Mark
in the Funky Bunch and then he did
Boogie Nights and he became an A-list
actor